hey hello sir you're like damn it man
yeah said I'm getting a ticket this time
72 and a 55 I understand I understand I
got you it's too fast I understand okay
I understand do you have the
registration for the
car
look well the question
is it says the oh oh purchase date
excellent an expiration day hot damn
feeling good about
that the last five of them if yeah yeah
that's the current one I got you is the
little man asleep is he is he buckled up
no he's not he's naked because see he
enough he went in a damn puddle oh no
and yeah
okay all right well just hang tight let
me do let me get some things done I'll
be right back all right thank hey Jess
good yes sir hey come on here for me let
me talk to you okay all
right all right hey com back so I want
to have a hardto heart conversation with
you okay I understand okay so and I'm
not putting it past you or anything but
I know you were
drinking yes all right so how much do we
have to drink I only had two drinks only
two yes okay all right that's an issue
though okay I understand okay I
understand that kind of puts me in a
position okay cuz at the end of the day
I still got to do my job okay I
understand all right so when was the
last rank you had Jessica uh I don't
know what time it is okay so it's it's
5:00 okay I to be honest I didn't write
it down or anything like that and I'm
not sure when I showed up was that when
did I see you that was I have no idea
why I want to say that was noon but um
and so it was after actually you know
what we showed up uh probably about
11:15 11:30 okay I feel like I saw you
at okay yeah it was about noon so you're
right and then I I just I got so no it's
f it happens timing wise okay so you
just had two drinks all right were they
the the the Dixie cup well the clear
Dixie cup y okay all right where were
they what were you drinking it was the
IPA IPA yep all right is she Ser well
she had drinks as well she had drinks as
well okay I know that's not hopeful no
it's not putting you in a shit position
yeah you are you really are I am really
sorry okay
I so I mean I I'm I'm telling you this
cuz I don't have a
strong hang on quick
okay hey can you hear
me yes sir hey come up to the Woodland
Baptist Church
please what you got I just have somebody
pulled over at 72 and at 55 I'll explain
it when I get when you get
here all right I'm coming that way I
just over South I'm coming to you all
right thank you sir that's my lieutenant
all right um all right so you just had
the two drinks yes sir okay um all right
so the first one was about what's that
no water either okay all right so the
first one was about 11:15 11:30 when I
saw you when was the second
one I I mean I just couldn't say it's
about 5 it's
okay I know but you see where the you
know I totally understand
I okay put you in more than a shit
situation yeah you did all right well
let me uh when he gets here I just want
to run through fil body test make sure
that you're okay to drive okay all right
do you know what a PBT is p your breath
test so what that does is I'll offer you
that at the end of these tests that I do
um it's it's up to you yes or no okay um
but what I'll do is I'll run through the
actual field ofar test with you
beforehand okay all right have you ever
been through anything like this before
all why
well I speed a lot you know you were
kind of coming in my Lane too oh I will
I apologize well it's okay I thought for
a second you were going to oh I apolog
yeah we were pretty close so all right
so she's been drinking too all right
yep 331 how far you
out I'm com in the car now way simple
just get you next door oh safety wise
you're fine I know you ain't got nothing
but good you never know these days
unfortunately I'm a minute or two from
your location you need
assistance negative 331 we'll do we
don't need a party down here so I'm just
going to get justice so the reason I
pulled you out to talk to you okay cuz I
can still it's not a strong heavy odor
okay but I can still smell a slight odor
of alcohol emitting off your breath okay
all right
well you saw me drinking too I I did yes
so but you know these fields body test
School
yep I know he knows you so does he
Lieutenant Justice Chris Justice do
youall know each other yeah I mean I
know he's been in the county since it
was born so well he knows the name at
least oh okay all right all just hang
tight right here for okay all right I'll
talk to you in a minute speaking with
him are you willing to take a pvt I
don't know what that is so what it's
going to do is going to let me know
whether you're a 0.008 and above or 8
and Below okay isn't blood test a more
accurate thing well so we have a blood
test is down the road blood test we
can't do right here obviously okay all
right now nobody's nobody's under arrest
okay so but with that being said I'm I'm
arer the pvt it's it's going to show me
whether you're below or or above okay
all right are you willing to do the pvt
it's not a best look yeah I can't use it
in cord it's just for here okay I I mean
I was always told by my parents don't
take that get the blood test okay I you
know what I mean you don't have the
optional blood test though okay yeah
because the way imply consent works if
if you were given a DUI yeah and pl
consent say if you're able to consent if
you're able to provide a sample and it's
available you take that okay and so does
the field sobriety test come first or we
can either do the PBT and field sobriety
test but we can um we can offer you the
pvt first we're prob by law to offer pvt
but it's not a in court it just lets us
know right here right now whether you
should be operating that vehicle or not
can't be against your court at all okay
okay do you think you're above 008 or
below I would like to think I'm below
okay I mean two drinks yeah it was about
11:15 11:30 when I will tell us
again it can't be us against your in
cour for anything let you know where
you're at right now lets us know whether
you should be driving whether maybe you
need to call somebody yeah but what I'm
so either way if I were above I mean
what ises that where does that put me
either way I feel I am e either way I'm
still going to run you through philar
test okay can we do that first yeah we
can is that possible the PB the PBT to
let you know where you're at if you want
to do the Fieldy test first PT just is
just another field so test so we're
required to offer you anyway with J I'm
not trying to help to you I've never
been in this situation
before yeah no I get that so the PBT p n
breath test is the field sobriety test
and it's going to be offered to you
regardless okay just whether you do it
in the front or whether you in the end
it doesn't make any difference if do it
in the front and say hypo hypothetically
speaking you're at a 04 let us know you
just need to call somebody okay well
that could also get me arrested
right4 no okay yeah are we sure about
that yes yes I mean I've been doing it
for almost 17 years get arrested today
no no I'm not going to peek you promise
but yeah I'm not going to yeah I'm not
going to hook you up on that I've been
doing this for almost 17 years it's not
going to get you arrested yeah like I
said he's been here a good person matter
of fact at a04 if you res for thei
that's what they use to release you4 or
below
drive all right in which case I take you
the call I can drive
to
get cuz yeah her passenger she said
she's had a few drinks as well
so sorry to put y'all in this position
it's okay all right so what you're going
to do is take a heavy deep breath in and
out like you're blowing a balloon up
constant steady breath okay okay so just
form a seill around the end of that tube
not all the way down here okay okay all
right blow blow blow blow keep blowing
keep blowing keep blowing keep blowing
keep
blowing
she's going to be right at
a08 083 this is what I would suggest
give it a couple of minutes and give
another one so just going up and coming
down yeah
okay
come on Jessica I sorry it's okay all
right let me want do the rest field
soety test then you get done with that
you can give another one see if it's
coming up com yeah let's do that okay
come up here I think this is a good spot
it's about as level as you going to find
well on this hill
yeah to this is about good right here
okay all right so what I'm going to have
you do I'm going to explain the test and
then I'll demonstrate it for you so
don't start any of the test until I tell
you to start the test okay so what I
want you to do is keep your feet
together just like so keep your hands
down by your side okay all right so what
I want you to do is follow the tip of my
finger okay all right with your eyes and
your eyes only okay okay do not move
your head all
right all right Jessica you're moving
your head head okay so your head's
moving this way okay so you got to keep
it still okay so your nose should be in
line with mine okay all right you
ready you wear eyeglasses or
contacts for surgery I do yes okay
but every day stuffff no
okay all
right I had this this all right so
or anything else I would say maybe come
right here it's a little bit flatter
okay right here do you feel comfortable
with this okay do you have no I got you
do you have any medical impairments from
your waist down knees ankles any
injuries right now ankle okay I ripped
the I ripped the tendons off the top of
my foot okay all right well I'll explain
the test if you don't you know and we'll
see if you can do it it okay all right
so what you're going to do is I'm going
to have you stay in what they call an
instructional stage okay okay so what
you're going to do is you're going to
take your left foot plant it hands down
by your side so your right foot is just
going to go like this okay all right all
right so I want you to stay in the stage
until I tell you to start the test okay
okay so do you feel comfortable right
there it's all right okay all right so
what you're going to do is you're going
to take nine hillt toe steps counting
your steps looking at your steps looking
at them yes okay okay all right so hold
on all right so once you're done with
the first set of nine steps what you're
going to do is take a series of small
steps to turn around facing this way
okay all right can you demonstrate yeah
I'm going to demonstrate I'm going to
explain everything and then I'm going to
demonstrate it but what I need you to do
is get back in the instructional stage
for me okay all right all right so when
you end the first set of nine steps all
right you're going to take a series of
small steps to turn around and come back
nine H Heel To Toe steps counting your
steps watching your steps hands down by
your side the entire test okay all right
do all that makes sense does now I'm
going to demonstrate it I love to
see okay all right so what you're going
to do is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so once you
get to that end of that first set like I
stated so you're just going to take a
series of small
steps but they don't have to be no just
a series of small steps to turn around
okay does all that make sense all the
instruction clear seems seems legit okay
so yes I need a yes sorry yes okay when
you're when you're ready
okay
one
two three
four
five
8 9 okay so the last test I'm going to
have you do here you you can stop you
can come out of that you're fine so the
last test I'm going to have you do is
what they call a one leg stand okay okay
so it's not that bad well I mean with my
leg it's hurt okay well whatever leg
that you feel comfortable with okay okay
so what you're going to do is I'm going
to explain it I'm going to demonstrate
it and then when you're ready to start
the test I'm going to have you do it
okay okay all right so what you're going
to do is whatever leg that you're
comfortable with you're going to raise
it approximately 6 in off the ground
facing outward just like that okay so
when you do this I want you to count 1,1
1,2 1,3 1,4 and so on until I tell you
to stop okay until you tell me to stop
yeah okay so it goes on for about 30
seconds okay I'm not going to set you
there for like 2 or 3 minutes I promise
okay but while we do this I want you to
keep your arms down by your side and you
need to look at that foot that you have
elevated okay okay I'm going to
demonstrate it for you okay okay all
right so like I said whatever leg that
you're comfortable with okay just like
this okay and 1001 100002 13 and so on
until I tell you to stop okay okay do
you understand the instructions I do
okay when you're ready side which leg
that's yes 1001 1002
10034 1005 1006 1007 1008 1009 100,0
1001 112
[Music]
202 fi party test we fine
so okay so like I said we do both tests
I'm not just going to hook you up on one
it's policy okay it's it's law so um you
follow the law yeah absolutely yeah had
put me in a position though okay really
have I I do understand that and I'm
sorry so no it's fine this this policy
so at the end of the day you know we got
to do our job you know that yep all
right
and all
right that's test
for would you mind doing another pv2 all
right come on let's see if he came down
a little bit okay
great you can get out if you want to
film I she's going to put this on
America's Most you
know nobody
want my mom said you haven't lived till
Social Services has called you but maybe
you haven't lived till you had a field
sobriety
test all right so just same thing heavy
deep breath in and out blow until I tell
you the step okay
just keep blowing keep blowing keep
blowing keep blowing blow blow
blow it's not enjoyable how it rolls up
like that I know I don't like that
either yeah it's getting slow though
so you're going
down
justice8 she's going
down I can't sit out here with you
that's going to be up to him no I can't
sit out here with you in another 10
minutes
so
all right just hang out with her at the
tailgate I'll talk to my lieutenant okay
thank
you you want to have a Ab conversation
say again AB
conversation well there's a
stag turn was fine stand was fine there
is a stag that's why I do more than just
those three tests I I still throw in the
alphabet and I throw in F of dexterity
other people do other tests that's why I
do more than just those three
standardized okay um I
08 I don't know whether she's going up
or coming down but if she still a0 she's
going she's going down it was a 083 last
time now she's a
080 I mean you got enough Terr rest on
on the segments and all I mean that's
why like I said I do more than just
those three s SP sobriety test um oh
those three the only ones you do
I mean I can do more no I'm saying
normally those three the only ones you
do yeah right just future refence make
want pick a couple more to do oh no I
usually no I I do sometimes I do more
usually I do the alphabet and numbers um
yeah how hard was in this diag it wasn't
that bad I it's there but it's very
slight
and I really wasn't watching the field
sobriety test and I didn't see the nagus
I know the O8 do you want to do no stag
i' give her no I'd give her a couple
more minutes go ahead and and if you're
going to do the summons go ahead and do
that and hit her another PBT and see
where she's at you also got to take into
account when you get her back to the
office still got to do PL observation
period before you do the breath by the
time I get down there she's going to be
she's coming down what is it going to be
by the time you get there yeah and then
you got the performance on the F variety
test that actually I wasn't watching I
was more watching the other person to
make sure they weren't doing so I'll
tell you this as far as the Stags it's
it's there but it's not
as
I very minimum very minimum she'd be
calling somebody to come get her yeah a
license driver yeah if you going to do
the ticket go ahead and do the ticket
and then off another PBT to see where
she's at okay all right let me work on
that then
all just I'm going to work on the
summons for speeding okay little man
he's unbuckled okay yes buckled now okay
well I I understand okay so I'm going to
give you a few minutes I'm going to work
this up and then we'll do another pvt
okay okay all right PE
yep what what have I pulled you over
before I know I pulled you over before a
Rolling Stock was it is that what it is
yeah rnia roll yeah good old roll all
right well let me explain this to you
okay all right so your record date for
this is going to be November 15th 201 23
at 9:00 a.m. I'm going to set you
7255 all right so by sounding this is on
admission of guilt sister promised to
appear this 4 dat this time this address
you do have the option to pay this okay
if you decide to pay it you don't need
to appear in court okay you can pay in
person pay in line or pay over the phone
y technically that's
reckless that's reckless though oh so
65 70 that's 15 starts at 70 7 you're
only no you're only no it's 80 yeah oh
yeah now if you would have came in at 75
that's where Reckless starts okay so
that's 20 mil over the speed L okay all
right sound right here
for just promise to appear pay
okay I'm we'll wait a few more minutes
I'll get you on
okay sir yep got to slow down I know
yeah my husband will have a f day with
us yes he is is have you met him I
have
Lieutenant reason right can 325 take
care of our burgly alarm off Davis
Creek all right you want to let him
now
you remember P Me Over My Little J who
have I not pulled you're you're the man
you did am there was what a month and a
half there you pull a lot of people
over can you say you're doing bad or
doing good you know well I haven't seen
you I guess so this the second time I've
seen her it two different cars yeah two
different cars it was late what did I
get
you uh just pass Death Valley I was 73
where's Death Valley
2,000
block oh well he wasn't at that Valley
he
was the sneak com nelon no no it's
Nelson it's Nelson it's if you going oh
oh oh I see p going Southbound okay we
call it death B cuz by the time by the
time you get to it just too late well
the cruise control got me I was
admittedly tired how many times have
heard that cruise control got well it
really did I was 73 on the bypass and
she kept 7 three yeah all the way
through
though the new car got me the other day
it's really
just I was on my way
to something was happening at Laur so I
was trying to get there and I was
following behind someone that the car
felt was safe enough but a car clear I
could tell my car
couldn't that they really needed to get
on that exit ramp you know and so they
just slid in front of me and went on the
my car locked up like I mean my chest
hit I I was like talk about you know
safety but gotcha yeah oh yeah yeah
scared the crap I mean I didn't know it
could do that they
get I was
[Music]
like
but I find it interesting has my what to
a gas station for a pepperoni I find
interesting how West Virginia American
going to say that an actual Italian
pepperon roll is not a good pepperoni
roll it's not it's not the same
essentially you just need to go to
Costco and buy pre-made dinner rolls
that's like buy pre-made tacos they just
don't get
it y'all are going to joke till I bring
you some pepperoni rolls and Y when you
talk about Max chin cot
shadies we have what I feel is okay safe
gas station gas station
food I feel Nelson County people have
like
this almost false sense of security when
it comes to gas station food and then
you go to like a fish fry or a you know
something weird at a different gas
station not from here and you should
maybe worry
more what is that
the so I've been I forgot where this gas
station is but you know the gas station
bathroom where Marco Myers gets changed
into I've been to one of those it was
terrifying so yeah oh it was
bad give up 2 minutes were y's thoughts
on the not spring up politics but that
camera thing that was taking pictures of
people to catch speeders in school's
Zs it has his benefits it also has it
downfalls I think even put up a decoy I
think that'd be
good at least it attempt to slow people
down so I I run the school zones so you
ain't got to worry about that I see yeah
she
I go 35 in those School Z I run school
zones too yeah yeah TI River get them
all the time yeah that's me every
morning well except for Tuesday it's
Monday through Friday I see you I see y
I see y well see that's that's a thing
too I'm glad y'all say that that y'all
see us because we get so much crap like
on Nelson well when y'all on the other
side par the tree and I'm going
Southbound and y'all are in the north
coming that's a little sneaky but you
got to be no no no no I'm talking about
people saying we're never there Oh no
you're absolutely there yeah you you got
to defend us on that side I will defend
you you are there yeah see I on a
regular basis I can show you camera
footage oh yeah I didn't know the school
you didn't see big lights but what I
guess what percentage I mean you don't
want to be exact is really the speeding
tickets for
that 29 is like a trap anyway I no where
no matter where you are so usually when
so usually as far as percentage as far
as how much we rate there yeah I mean I
pr decent yeah oh yeah I'll set I'll end
up so just between the morning and with
Ty River and the Middle High School Zone
I get about six tickets in the morning
yo yeah oh so I was so there was this
rumor about you that you could write 40
tickets in a day I've done it before Oh
so so that's true so and someone said no
the average is only like one an hour and
I was but you know how rumors are so you
don't know you can actually write two in
an hour yeah you have a
limitation he's just saying how many we
can write an
hour you're super efficient actually aod
I usually I usually write about 100 of
mon I have a question is it true that if
I mean you go to court judge 's like
that's okay just pay your court
fees you can look it up I mean you feel
like that's a lot of them or he's like n
you were speeding you he he is actually
he'll take his time
you know why are speeding that brings
meice here's the thing about speed traps
if you're not speeding you don't have to
true all right you
ready you get Hammer every you broke I
got to wait till it says blow there you
go keep blow blow blow blow blow blow
blow blow blow blow blow
blow good thing I don't have asthma true
yeah
32 they do want to put a
camera put a camera still 8 seriously
yeah I was wondering I was
like
justice
all
right yeah yeah WR so here here's the
thing she's still 0 Z all right there's
a stag St Fior test with f as far as the
walking term one leg
standand but I know that what is the
presumptive level 05 to
0808 yes it's presumptive but it's how
you going articulate
your and again I wasn't watching I
watching other person think sure they
for okay so it's what you feel
comfortable what you I don't think I
don't think I had I mean I can tell you
this there's no not enough inag it's
there but not enough so I'll leave it at
that we're going to have a talk there
that's I say it's your yeah your sto
your stop I just don't want people think
I'm doing favoritism because if she was
falling down oh yeah oh that's one thing
but how can youate the she needs to call
somebody though and that's all in your
articulation
yeah all right just Let's Have a Heart
to Heart come
here all right so the stagis yes you
know what that is yes I do it's there
yes okay so that's an indicator okay
okay you're walking turn you're one leg
stand I'm going to be honest with you so
you're walking turn one leg standing
fine okay I've seen worse I've seen
better okay
um based off field soety test I know
you're still 08 obviously I can't I
can't arrest you Bas just based off your
PBT
um with that being said with just the
nagus it was there but it wasn't I've
seen worse lot lot worse okay so I don't
feel that I have enough to place you
under rest of but you're still at 08 you
got to call somebody okay let's do that
now okay okay all right let's get that
done okay all right two well I'm allowed
to be in the vehicle you're allowed to
be in the vehicle you just can't be I
said abandon the vehicle well I mean if
you need to set it here that's fine okay
yeah but just let's go and make that
call so I can yes yeah go and do that
for me all right thank
you take
that did you get my goods out at least
yeah I did I was really nice to you and
I think you felt bad for pulling the
little pink car over I was like thank
you and you were
like was that mean no you were really
nice I was nice to you too yeah I mean
that go today you were like you know how
fast you were going I was like not
exactly but I was going fast you're like
73 and a sexy and I was like I believe
you make 87 100
oh yeah you got 100 what about a month
ago coming through 29 Davis cre fastest
I've had on 29 was
117 so grinning while I was hooking him
up he was just grinning happy as he
could be yeah hey was he Ricky Bobby no
first your last last you was just having
a good time like okay cool let me put
this PBT up real
[Music]
quick actually I'm I'm curious do you
want to do a pvt well see where you're
at she said it's hard to blow through
man to blow through well Christian's
was but that was all for fun I did not
get this is just
yeah shoot if you come in at like a 01
or 02 I'll let
you we live beside each other so it
would be convenient there you go I don't
know where Buck is her
husband what oh I'm doing it to see what
I'm
blowing so why not all right until it
clicks right yep heavy deep breath in
and out and I'll tell you when to stop
blowing okay just for a still around
that
tube keep blowing blow blow blow blow
blow blow blow keep blowing keep blowing
keep blowing keep blowing there you
go you look at me look at this not
[Music]
me yeah you already so the presumptive
level is 05 to 8 that you're under the
influence of back hall so that's a noo
that's a noo yeah you wouldn't be able
to yeah you
been there you go souvenir it
is well I mean it's definitely going to
be talked
about
I got the r car this time
yeah all right J Who's Coming bla Ashley
do you know him I don't
know
uh it's not Steven's C Mountain Co so he
ain't too far no okay I kind Mi looking
at my old car and my new car oh I was
hoping that's what you going yeah I know
I know I know was about what c yeah it
was that i' be like
well that vcro
rip what you thinking
me yeah you oh this is unfortunate yeah
no actually wasn't thinking about I I
know this sounds weird than you
stop no so the other day Ethan asked
well other day couple months ago asked
you if you would talk to me about the
whole
situation talk to you about the whole
situation if I would
yeah I though I don't love being on the
other end of the
law I love a man there where I know
where they stand I there's something to
be said for
that and I actually really don't know
who to vote for I you know what I mean
it's like they're cut from the same damn
cloth in my
opinion and and you want to know how I
see it cuz I judge people pretty
decently as soon as the rutherfords turn
against Embry he will be
Hill I don't I know that sounds
horrible and sucks for
y'all 6 months in at our level we're
just out here trying to do I oh I know I
know it's just I don't know I don't well
it's not like I convince one people or
the other
but I don't know it's police are so
important so important here's the
husband
your money get a tip nope if I need to
talk to him I will if if he does have
any
questions so the biggest thing she needs
to take away this away from this if
she's going to drink just don't drive
just get somebody driving this
over yeah take
a your head look here's what you do
you want go I'll take your way to get in
wherever going there were so many people
there I know she could have got a ride
so just call somebody you been just call
somebody hey can you come get me I'm not
and and and to be
honest I'm not too happy with you
because you got in a car with somebody
that's been drinking yeah so God forbid
something happened true that yeah not to
be excuse like but yeah she's my boss
and my landlord I get it but I'm going
I'm going take tell you about something
that happened not too long ago okay me
and my chef partner out working night
time up in h nobody called it in sh
happy to find a
wreck he drove by it once he see it he
came back by it saw it got out with it D
was drunk and trapped in the
vehicle from Passenger dead damn drun at
this dver broke all up pass your
dead I me for being hon she scared me on
a daytoday basis what they're
driving so that's actually yeah just the
one that uh they came off coling road R
the step sign she was under the
influence of Narcotics passenger was
dead she lived she's in jail for the
rest of her life y
so
now I know that nobody would want to
live rest of their life knowing they had
made that decision and call someone
maybe a family not baby back there
they're
lives
so just poop all not trying to brow beat
nobody just poop all how did that
conversation
go I married that man cuz he's pretty
non-judgmental there you go he is
coordinating with bla how to get the car
okay it's not anybody's job judge
anybody him up
there the guy I dated before this guy
you should talk to I have arrested
people you probably think I'm a ter
person no it's not my job just
and I I'll tell them the same thing I
tell you what happened is you made a bad
choice and the bad choice got you in the
spot you're in today so now you have two
rows to go down Road a the one I hope
you take is you learn something just
take them away from it and you don't
make those kind of choices again you can
call that a learning experience like
full of them yeah Road B the one I hope
you don't take if you don't learn
anything from it don't take away from it
you keep making these same bad choices
they become mistakes mistakes will bite
you in the backside every single time
it's up to you to pick which Ro you want
to go down yep Su all that up just get a
DD true yeah okay just find somebody
that's over there was plenty of people
there just okay get your DD right with
you hey I'll pay you away if you want to
come drive me home they get a free trip
out of it and you get a good ride home
that that that that that is one thing
that you know I'm not a big fan of
somebody drinking and then driving okay
I I understand that and I'll tell you
what I just told your your co-pilot here
also
not not this long ago me and my chef
partner wereing night shift couple
months up in a he found a wreck wasn't
wasn't called in B went over the bank
into a tree broadside for shooted the
vehicle around the tree hit it hard
enough to knock the engine block
completely out of the
car the driver was broke all to a
million pieces and trapped in the car
trumping the SC his front seat passenger
dead on the
seat driver was 24 years
old P's about the same
age now the driver's got to
live thinking about that knowing that he
killed his friend yep until of a
choice was really young to learn that
lesson imagine being his
parents the parents of the Dead FR
passion from the 20s and now they're not
here anymore
yeah
the way they played out the driver
didn't make it to the Lane Zone
really not trying to BR Beach no no no
you're just stting truth B watch asph
when you in
driver's in almost 17 years here I can't
remember how many times I've been to a
crash te called by DUI
driver other people
did my aunt she's a nurse she said the
only way to really survive a accident is
to be drunk because they just kind of
Bounce Around they
don't like that was saying that long ago
the woman in right here K
duid killed somebody
else just not a good idea no you're
ready and on the monetary side the first
EV DUI webly got
k figureing attorney fees CR CER fines
ins ignition ignition interlock that you
have to pay to install you have to pay
to maintain and you have to pay to take
out they do that for like six months
yeah based out courses time you total
everything up right around 10 grand for
a first well so that's not even
including insurance
no that's just your legal stuff that's
not counting your
insurance and the headache you get when
you get home the next day spend a night
in drunk tank be sober before they
release you then you go home with your
nonjudgmental husband might be just a we
bit judgmental cuz now you messing with
his money cuz the insurance will go
through the true true and you've lost
the vehicle potentially for
sure just not a good idea
NOP yeah while we're here do you have
any questions comments concerns anything
that you need
to is there anything you think I should
know
no I I just don't want to see in this
you know see I just don't want to see
you like this again okay oh no I yeah no
I agree all right I agree just I mean
it's and I'm not trying to push you but
don't don't just get a DD just like I
said
okay2 years old somewhere she's going to
drink I don't I drive what he driving a
Jeep if I'm going to drink she he
driving a Jeep uh BL
is dark light brown same color as yeah
Jeep's pulling up yeah that's
him so see know what's going on oh yeah
all right he didn't come from there did
he no he came from the he came our
man could be doing better
yes this is bla Ashley nice meet you
wison just she needs a DD next time just
push that into her head please gotcha
okay all right get what you need I
appreciate
yep you have to transfer the child yeah
or do you want to drive this and come
back or come back and get that that'll
work you better lock
it Sor you're meeting me this way just
just keep it in mind just like I said I
can't say it enough just get a DD it's
not that hard okay you're right it's not
at all you want to shake hands again
yeah I mean there we go all right at
least keeping some good turns you know
oh yeah absolutely well I I do
appreciate what yeah app you all meet
people on their worst freaking day oh
yeah all right unfortunately yeah true
all right well good to go all right
thank you again thank you
sir you need to take a walk of shame
when you get home
yeah yeah